this is from KRON4 U.S Capitol Police
Officer dies after violent protests
bring debt bringing death toll to five
they say U.S Capitol police officer has
died from injuries sustained during
violent riots at the Capitol on
Wednesday a source tells K Ron's four
Alexandra Limon that the police officer
was hit in the head with a fire
extinguisher by a rider and was taken
off life support the police officer is
now the fifth person to die as a result
of the violent protests the other four
who have died identified as Rosalind
Roseanne Boyland now my understanding is
she was she fell and they believed she
was trampled
Kevin Gleason and Benjamin Phillips I'm
not entirely sure which one but one of
them suffered a heart attack one of them
suffered a stroke
and Ashley Babbitt of course she was the
woman who had climbed up in the window
and peeked through and the officer shot
her killing her now look you know
apparently some you know couple people
had heart attack and and one guy had a
heart attack one got a stroke they're
trying to lump that in to make that seem
like that's part of the actual riotous
death count and I think that might be a
little disingenuous although I guess if
you if you know if you have suffer a
medical emergency because you're older
and you're the moment you blood flow and
all that stuff you're going crazy and
your heart's pounding I guess it makes
sense but it wasn't like those people
died because of external forces it was
just you know their bodies giving out as
for uh you know Ashley Babbitt she got
killed and what was she really doing but
just climbing up and looking through a
window I mean come on it's not like it's
like I'm gonna sit here and say that
these people should have been the
building of course not but I'm just I
tell you man I have seen these
circumstances a bunch of people run in
the building you see people who don't
know what's going on who walk up and
they're just bumbling around confused
I've talked about it over and over again
that what happens is someone runs up to
a door and hits the glass runs away
someone else runs up and sees the glass
falling and knocks out some pieces runs
away it's all these little grains of
sand that eventually the doors open and
mindless people are just like walking up
and seeing the door open and walking and
going like wow what's going on and then
you end up with this woman now she's got
social media videos you know Ashley
she was very adamant she was very angry
at staunch Trump supporter
but this this shouldn't have happened I
mean even if you know people were
storming the capital it's it's it's it's
it's
absurd in my opinion nah I gotta be
honest I get it you storm the capital
you got itchy trigger fingers from
Capital Security and it's their job to
barricade the doors and protect the
people inside and it's just completely
tragic now I'll tell you I I'm also mad
about this cop losing his life because
this is a look
I say this about the left all the time
they think the cops know what they're
talking about you see a cop and they're
like he's he should know what I know and
so they scream Trader whose side are you
on and that cop doesn't necessarily know
what you know now I think it's fair to
say a lot of trump supporters a lot of
conservatives probably assume the cops
know a bit because they're cops and they
deal with this stuff all year
but I'm I'm not gonna pretend that you
know when you see cops going around and
destroying small businesses throughout
the lockdown just like blocking doors
yeah that that we see in New York and
stuff violates the first amendment when
they when they when they're secretly
filming you know Jewish schools that is
creepy and it also violates the right to
worship and assemble when they're
shutting down churches these were cops
who were providing basic security to our
government who are standing around
saying we want to make sure everybody
inside can do their job somebody bash
this guy over with a fire extinguisher
why why kill the guy why would you do
that
oh man it's just it's just infuriating
yeah um you know many news organizations
and even some individuals are talking
about thoughts and prayers for the
traumatized Congress members people
forget that people died here this is a
very serious incident specifically
talking about that woman you know
there's a lot of videos we still don't
know the full details we hope there's an
investigation but but it doesn't look
Justified and right now we're getting
the information that the chief of the
U.S Capitol Police is saying that the
police officer involved in that fatal
shooting has been placed on
administrative leave and their police
Powers have been suspended pendant
investigation another thing that really
needs to be pointed out scared cop with
a gun man
um yes but then also he was behind the
door there's a lot of different elements
that we could break down here but
another important one is that there was
police officers with like full on long
rifles tactical behind her yeah the
police officer could have killed other
police officers and and and and there
was no threat to anyone one's life and
again I don't want to be jumping to
conclusions because I do hope there's an
investigation we do need to wait for
cooler hits to Prevail before making any
kind of assumptions and judgments here
but but just looking at that video
footage we should really prioritize the
truth about that event rather than you
know in in my opinion you can't even
compare the two the the nonsense the the
hysteria the the just hyperbolic bull
crap on mainstream media right now oh I
mean CNN's ratings are through the roof
so of course they're going after Trump
hard yeah you know but but look we got
more news here pertaining to the police
U.S Capitol Police Chief to resign after
Wednesday's riots I mean so there you go
that's the news it's a Stephen Sund is
resigning amid criticism over an
apparent lack of preparedness to deal
with Wednesday's violent mob on Capitol
Hill you know I I was I was on Twitter
and I was about to tweet something like
why weren't the police ready for this
and then I stopped and thought about
what I had just said when I made a
segment on YouTube and said I don't
think I'm supporters will do anything I
think they're going to go they're going
to support Trump they're going to Rally
they're going to wave American flags and
they're going to March around I didn't
think there are any people who actually
you know storm the barricades now
there's there's a couple of videos one
of them shows the cops retreating as the
the group pushes through but there's a
bunch of different areas there's also an
overhead view of all of the barricades
and a massive crowd shaking the
barricades knocking them down then
rushing the stairs up to the building so
I mean look that might have been my
video because I was up in that um were
you filming down I was up in the media
tower well so let's let's set up for
inauguration let's uh uh let let's do
this let me get your thoughts on uh on
on you know this officer and these
people lost their life and then we'll go
into your story about everything that
went down so you know just like I don't
know tell me what you think about what
the violence and all that stuff so I
mean first off I arrived basically when
they had already amassed around the
capital and the police had set up their
line so right when I arrived uh the
first thing I noticed was not only were
the police using mace and bear spray but
they also were uh the protesters were
using it as well on the police and the
police were less adequately equipped
than I was as a reporter I had a
tactical helmet and a gas mask and
because I had seen the reports and I
rushed down there and um you turned them
sorry and uh so when I got there I was
extremely surprised to see how
unprepared the police were usually in
these kind of situations you know where
things are escalating you see Riot
police pour out but the people who had
formed the lines they were all just
basically you know your standard uh
Capitol Police maybe they had a shield
over their face if they were lucky but
no gas masks but these these these
people who are in the front and you know
spraying the cops and stuff who were
they were they Trump supporters because
we're hearing a lot of people are trying
to claim especially conservatives that
it was actually antifa but I've I've
seen one video where there's a guy who
does not look like a trump supporter but
he's got a trump sticker on his helmet
bashing a window just like antifa does
and people are screaming stop him and
then a trump supporter grabs him and
puts him in a neck hold and pulls him
down yeah that's also extremely
underreported yeah what you just brought
up is an important facet that there were
elements from videos that I've seen with
people saying stop this yeah I'm curious
I'm curious from you guys because
there's two kind of theories out there
one is that there was inadequate
security and that the police officers
let them in another one was that they
were just not ready and they were
overtaken there's these two theories
what what do you guys think from your
personal opinions what actually happened
yesterday it's kind of a a mix with both
they were for sure not prepared under
manned
um I kind of went into the kind of went
into it the same sentiment of Tim
actually even reporting on the ground
was I didn't think anything crazy was I
actually was anticipating more black
lives matter actors maybe making their
way down and then you know just because
that's what we've seen in the past but
from what I what I saw is if they were
for sure unprepared but to me I didn't
see anything that like jumped out and
said
um you know these were antifa like I
just you know I know that's not popular
to say right now you see that video
where they're yelling no antifa no stop
him stop but then again like when there
were these claims summer that you know
right Wingers were infiltrating antifa
and BLM protests what were they you know
did umbrella man wear a Maga hat when he
did the crime yeah so antifa's not going
to dress up as antifa
um if they're you know trying to well
these you know what I mean yeah but so
so some of these so it's impossible to
tell really just because they have a red
hat on doesn't really well no these guys
didn't they had like a brown helmet and
then just like black block Gear with a
trump stick around it and I'm like the
dude geared up and then slip a sticker
on his home and make it seem like he's a
trump supporter no this is interesting
because we've seen the media during the
summer trying to obfuscate some of the
kind of left-wing protest as undercover
right Wingers there was government
officials mainstream media you know
politicians saying no these aren't you
know left-wing antifa these are
right-wingers trying to incite us to
make us look bad now we're seeing a kind
of similar kind of attempt here do you
think it's legitimate or because other
people are also adding that there wasn't
any kind of counter protest when there
usually is that's what people are saying
I don't to jump to conclusions I just
want to kind of hear your opinions on
this I think from just from my
perspective is emotions are super high
right now even from a reported
perspective like even right after
election if you just told the truth
about the election people are are
unfalling you and canceling you if you
don't tell them what they want to hear
if you don't say Trump's going to be in
office after January 20 you're done so I
I was already seeing that and then this
I think is just adds on top of it like I
said
um I don't know what what's going on but
it just seems like no one wants to take
responsibility it seems like antifa's
just the easy scapego like just anything
hey auntie fantiva look even before
every Everything broke down when I was
doing interviews I was I was asking
folks do you think this is kind of a
civil war that we're headed because what
look whether you agree with the save uh
the stop the rally March in DC that
moment is historic because we've never
seen anything like that after a
presidential election so we're already
walking on you know uncharted waters so
with with this situation to me
um like I said I was asking folks do you
think we're headed to a Civil War I was
19 out of ten they're saying this is a
civil war to us this is a revolution not
to mention like all the crowbars yes
like people were telling me that implies
premeditation what is a crowbar used for
like what for holding up a sign no
absolutely not for breaking the doors
open correct people had crowbars oh I
saw probably five or six crowbars a lot
of them actually were just left by the
doors where the glass had been shattered
what yeah I got because I got knocked
down by one of the doors and I actually
was looking for my phone and I found a
crowbar that's so weird man
I don't know
I mean I just think everyone's emotional
right now you know what I think I I
don't know it's just it's just we never
breaking in you know I guess maybe in
the 1700s taking the State Building may
have granted you some kind of power I
don't know how that works I guess you're
like I'm in the building it's mine now
uh especially not today you know they
can issue a statement from wherever they
want anyway these politicians going in
the building didn't do anything you know
I mean we've got videos of I tweeted
this out uh the women's March took over
the Senate building and then they shut
the whole building down
and they weren't worried about the fact
that there was like a thousand plus
people screaming at the top of their
lungs inside oh is that that in heart
was that hard Senate Office Building
yeah yeah that big like um The Atrium
yeah right exactly that's heart yeah so
I understand it's a fairly different
circumstance that you know storming
through the barricades and fighting with
cops and pepper spraying them and
smashing windows and breaking is very
different plus it was during the
Electoral you know vote count so you
know I just I wonder what the goal is
for either group like the women's Market
didn't accomplish anything what did they
accomplish really yesterday other than
some people have lost their lives
it I mean to me just yeah you don't
accomplish anything it just seems like
Trump just lost a whole bunch of support
we've seen now the Senators kind of
rescind their objections and now this
also gives big Tech the big excuse in
the world as we're seeing to just censor
Trump I mean it just seems like after
the election Trump is going to disappear
on social media I don't know oh it's
already basically yeah he's definitely
banned from Facebook now according to
Mark Zuckerberg's own personal post the
New York Times yesterday had two
articles talking about the importance of
limiting speech and we are seeing people
left right and Center just being taken
down for the minuscule post and even
memes there's a meme of that guy who's
wearing the the kind of weird headgear
in the face paint and it says you know
2021 uh I thought it wasn't going to be
crazy and Facebook is Banning people's
account for that post and it's not even
a political post it's not even taking
side it's a joke it's a meme it's people
saying this year is pretty crazy banned
on Facebook and they just released these
vague terms terms saying if you are
supportive of this in any way you you
get cut Michelle Obama just released a
statement talking about how you know
it's dangerous to have social media but
there's a big argument I want to make
here and I really want to kind of talk
about the dangers of censorship
especially when it comes to Q Anon
because when we look at Q Anon this was
a movement that was essentially censored
but the conversation didn't end it was
festered and moved into the dark corners
of the internet where it grew that
conversation could have been addressed
could have been handled in a way where
people could actually talk about it in a
rational real way instead of just going
on this bizarreness there could be
people pushing back yes one of the
problems with parlor for instance and
I'm not here to rag on parlor in terms
of what it is I'm just saying one of the
problems philosophically is that when
you when all the Trump supporters leave
Twitter because they ban Trump they go
to parlor where they no longer hear the
arguments from the other side and the
same is true for the left the problem is
the longest time Twitter has just been
Banning arguments from the right so the
left only hears their own refuse back at
themselves and Trump supporters leave
and then start doing their own refuse
back at themselves not just Twitter
Facebook and YouTube also going after
who people who are debunking the Q Anon
stuff people who are saying hey let's
take a legitimate look let's look at the
evidence let's look at the accusations
let's actually look at this and they
were debunking Q Anon stuff independent
creators had their channels taken down
because they were doing that YouTube
YouTube yes
I had to go through all my old videos
being like okay I can't even talk about
this and I and I removed some of them
because YouTube was on a huge Purge
against Q Anon and whether you're
against it or for it and that is
something that really pushed the
conversation that made people on The
Fringe even more Fringe even more
extreme and they and they were coming
back and saying well if we're not
legitimate why is YouTube blocking us we
must be against the system
say this over Target exactly we're over
the Target because we're getting the
Flack we're getting censored and and
this is why I'm against censoring speech
and this is why this is is an extremely
dangerous time because a lot of people
are using this situation to push for
extreme censorship and the destruction
of civil liberties they they've censored
the president of the United States I
mean look you can you can complain I I
think his uh the tweets he put out where
he said this is what happens when a you
know great and Gloria's Landslide has
taken you know but then he did go home
and peace never forget this day it was
far from a perfect statement Trump could
have done way better and so I think I I
can be somewhat critical it was kind of
a tepid statement the left is of course
freaking out about it it wasn't an overt
Act of support or anything like that but
it was pretty close to it but regardless
of what you think about that they
removed him they took down the president
that's crazy to me and they're probably
going to take down the rest of his
social media uh and they're probably
going to make sure that he never has a
voice in this kind of larger political
discourse like he previously had before
and this is a president where it's going
to be set where the tech rolling Elites
Mark Zuckerberg is going to decide what
you can and cannot hear Michael Tracy
had a very interesting point about this
that I think is is worth talking about
he said quote philosopher king Mark
Zuckerberg should definitely get to
unilaterally decide based on his
subjective political judgment which
definitely is not dictated by the
fleeing passions of the day whether the
public is allowed to hear from the
elected president good system and he
makes a good point there uh but but
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live don't forget to subscribe hit the
like button hit the notification Bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there thanks for hanging out and
we will see you all next time